fue solo un recuerdo durante 500 días
pero la luz del sol volvió a acariciar
el rostro del atleta de élite española
Beatriz flamini Muchas gracias entró en
una cueva el 21 de noviembre de 2021 y
salió este viernes 14 de abril su equipo
de apoyo hecho de espeleólogos
nutricionistas y psicólogos la esperaba
con los brazos abiertos en la superficie
para celebrar con ella su nuevo récord
del mundo casi un año y medio de
aislamiento a 70 metros bajo tierra sin
comunicación Este es el secreto para
lograrlo según flamini
stas en pasado y en futuro es decir si
tú estás en dónde estás en tu presente
pero tu mente está en lo que dejas atrás
o en lo que vas a encontrar en el en el
pasado entras en
ansiedad no
o sea entonces el truco está en el aquí
en el ahora la deportista intentó
calcular el paso del tiempo Durante los
primeros dos meses de la experiencia
hasta que desistió y empezó a medirlo
con sus procesos fisiológicos como su
periodo o las veces que tenía que ir al
baño
precisamente Este era uno de los
objetivos de esta Aventura extrema
comprender Qué le sucede al cuerpo y a
su ritmo circadiano al privarlo de las
medidas externas del tiempo además
flamini también quería filmar un
documental sobre su vida cotidiana bajo
tierra leyendo Tejiendo escribiendo y
sobre todo pensando mucho
surgen cosillas Y tal Pero no
son anécdotas ya están
estoy muy agradecida estoy muy contenta
y
no sé la memoria de flamini se quedó
anclada en noviembre de 2021 cuando el
mundo todavía no había atravesado la
oleada de omi cron y ahora se encontrará
de nuevo la vida sin mascarillas Tampoco
sabía nada de la guerra que estalló en
Ucrania ni de la muerte de la reina
Isabel II en Inglaterra o de la
coronación de Lionel Messi como campeón
del mundo
además de una experiencia única el
aislamiento le deja Beatriz problemas de
memoria a corto plazo o de concentración
con ellos deberá volverse a adaptar a la
vida en la superficie de 2023